i'm performing sunday nights and my song
the bones which is nominated for best
country songs are good
it's been a couple years since i've
performed on the grammy stage so i'm
just really happy to be back
and i'm so happy that they're doing it
safely in person
it just feels like a real show and so
i'm
very excited to be a part of it i found
out i was nominated
um i was listening because it was on
twitter
so i was it was bluetooth through my car
speaker because i was driving on my way
to somewhere
in nashville and they were announcing
the country song category and i heard
my name and the bones and it's just
really special to me because
country song is songwriters that are
awarded and nominated and to be
nominated
at the grammys for a song like the bones
which i wrote years ago and it's taken
on such a bigger meaning
it just marks the end of a really
beautiful journey i've taken with
the bones and um to share it this way on
the grammy stage
as well as you know it being nominated
just feels wonderful
i'm performing bluebird and i haven't
got to sing this song
really at all because it was a single
right in the middle
of or at the beginning of 2020 so you
know the band and i got together and
rehearsed it here on
on monday and just made sure we we
hadn't played it much so
i'm just excited to sing it and the set
is beautiful
it's very ethereal and there's like this
peaceful vibe it's got a lot of flowers
so i'm excited about it
this year felt extra special to be
nominated because
it was just such a bright spot
especially for
for music you know we haven't been able
to do what we love to do
so getting to come to the grammys and
perform and have your
you know your songs celebrated it means
the world
my performance at the grammys is going
to be
so special and emotional like it's not
just about me
there's it's this song black like me
it is so many people's stories
and that was my goal in this performance
there's representation
as well which is really important to me
in this performance but i just wanted
people to feel like they're coming
together this is a huge moment for black
people in country music
and i just feel so honored to
stand in these shoes right now
getting my first grammy nomination for
black like me
means the absolute world to me
i've been pursuing music for a very very
very long time
and there are many times that i thought
i was going to quit and
my music journey didn't change until
i stopped running away from who i really
am
embracing who i really am and
opening the door for other people other
people that are marginalized
and then that's when my career turned
around and
this moment shows that and i have a baby
so there's so i had a new baby and
and all of those moments right now like
i i can't even really
express how i really feel because it is
so overwhelming
it's it's overwhelming i guess is the
way i could express how i feel
right now i'm honoring john pryan at the
grammys and
he is one of my great heroes he's
certainly one of the greatest
songwriters of all time and
there's so many of us that just wouldn't
we wouldn't write songs and we wouldn't
know how
if it weren't for john there's something
about this performance for me that's
really cathartic because it's springtime
and it's been a year almost since we
lost him
and i just feel like there's hope and
redemption in the words of this song so
i'm looking forward to being able to
honor him in this way because i wanted
to do it all year
and couldn't get out of the house